pop
m
pour
[Musique]
et
alors est ce que mr besson il ya
beaucoup de choses encore à vide et on
se dépêche alors le hobbit me dit oh que
c'est trop dans le fond se défonce du
fond toujours là-bas dépêchez-vous vie
hippie dépêchez vous là bas oui oui
madame
allez-y weimert dans le fond
dépêchez-vous joué assez de l'homme j'ai
mal aux bonbons et oui les chaînes je
vous interdis ne vous en faites pas ça
n'est pas ce que vous croyez
et maintenant mesdames et messieurs ce
que vous allez découvrir dans quelques
instants c'est tout simplement le
monument le plus célèbre du monde
320 mètres de haut 73 ans d'existence
trois étages avec ascenseur au gaz
électricité télévision noir les couleurs
antennes collectives
la merveille de l'exposition de 89 le
paradis des pickpockets la providence
des suicides et le phare de la france
j'ai nommé à tout appel
[Musique]
c'est alors nouvel ace de tour eiffel
ben voyons
hélas mesloise monsieur on vient de
voler la tour eiffel vous nick verlaine
nick vers l'est
[Musique]
disparition tour eiffel risque de porter
un coup très grave à la saison
touristique
depuis ce matin en effet des milliers de
voyageurs venus ici à paris dans le seul
but de voir de contempler lustres
monument se précipitent aux guichets des
gares ou des aérodromes fuyant paris qui
pour eux n'est plus paris sans la tour
eiffel je veux maintenant interviewé
questionnaire son nombre de passagers
qui justement quitte paris monsieur
monsieur s'il vous plaît monsieur vous
êtes américains oh non je suis chez moi
mais pourquoi quittez-vous paris claude
turri faire merci monsieur madame madame
madame excusez moi vous êtes hollandaise
je suis bien mais pourquoi quittez-vous
paris le tour eiffel merci madame
je vais maintenant questionné à notre
passage en voit maintenant monsieur
monsieur s'il vous plaît vous êtes
brésilien pakistanais et vous retournez
à karachi maintenant non à peshawar
mais à cause de la tour eiffel j'ai
oublié de fermer le gaz
bon revenons au fond de la sphère la
police est sur les dents suspect numéro
un nick verlaine évidemment le
spécialiste mondial du vol rocambolesque
et dont on a cru relevé l'empreinte du
pied droit en bordure ouest du champ de
mars
mais tout d'abord qui est nick verlaine
nous avons posé la question aux
commissaires poilvert ni verlaine le
voilà vous allez voir comme c'est
commode
[Applaudissements]
portrait robot de nick verlaine après le
vol mystérieux du cyclone banana aux
antilles un portrait robot de nick
verlaine après le vol de la flamme
olympique entre athènes et munich
celle qui éclaire le stade n'était pas
la vraie d'ailleurs vous avez vu le
résultat
idem après le vol du chapeau de
l'empereur aux invalides et ce1 et ce1
et celui ci est de tous ces portraits ne
pourrait-on pas tirer un portrait robot
global définitif
nous l'avons fait le voilà ou bien c'est
un sosie ou bien c'est une erreur coucou
pardon jeudi coucou me revoilà c'est moi
qui - verlaine nique
c'est au sujet de la tour eiffel non
montparnasse vous me la faites sauter je
vous remets l'autre qu'elle ouvre eiffel
nous rendrons ainsi à paris son vrai
visage
c'est au marché non c'est du chantage
bien entendu je vous laisse un petit
délai de réflexion à l'eau alors
question tour eiffel vous inquiétez pas
elle est en lieu sûr
villefranche sur mer son vieux port de
guerre sa citadelle du xviie salles
obscures du 13e sa chapelle saint pierre
des corps épars cocteau et sa tour
eiffel volée par nick v
là
[Rires]
aa à aa à aa
[Applaudissements]
l'amérique
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
nicolas les requins attaquent
qu'est ce que c'est toi tu rêvais encore
que tu as volé la tour eiffel en
disséquant là il faut absolument voir un
médecin
c'est inquiétant après cette obsession
mais qu'est ce que tu dirais si je
l'avais toutes les nuits que je chante
walkyrie à loperhet part ça je dirais
qu'à toi ça risque pas de taille
voilà voilà c'est bien ce que je dis ou
tina que jamais à ma carrière qu'il y
met bien sûr que non je ne suis pas
derrière moi
mélac mais norma là le sydela melman
l'ère de la magie mais combien la tour
eiffel il faut tenir
je n'imagine pas jour c'est parce que ça
peut arriver mais pourquoi pas ne sait
jamais mais complètement fou alors les
renseignements oui je redeviens ça vous
à l'adresse d'un bon psychiatre ni trop
vieille trop jeune ni trop cher comment
mais vous êtes les renseignements vous
n'êtes pas les renseignements
il n'y a pas deux mais mademoiselle
si vous êtes et renseignements de nos
boîtes de l'enseignement
si tout le monde contre elle moi
[Musique]
non
qu'est ce que tu fais je n'ai pas le
temps de descendre à us et comme j'en
mets mon piano poêlé ou jeunes armés
quelle question
mais moi je ne suis pas contre toi
c'est pourquoi team et les défauts c'est
parce que c'est comme ça que je t'aimais
je t'aime et je t'aimerai allons
vraiment à dire que je ne suis pas
contre toi je dois regrette pas ce que
j'ai envie d'être contre toi mais tous
contre toi alors oui c'est oui c'est moi
là je fais pour moi ah bon à l'eau
j'écoute
[Musique]
oui quoi
pour les plus hauts
est ce que vous dites est paré pou sont
même pas l'asie
[Applaudissements]
maintenant je fais ça et au bureau ou
une agence immobilière ça ne se dirige
pas tout seul et quand le patron n'est
pas là il était ma mère je dis tu vas
pas que j'y vais avec toi un nom quand
je suis très pressé j'ai pas le temps
que tu veux quand même partir de chats
ou presque allez on voit même type à
colas tu veux que je te dise toute façon
tu le dira quand même alors y'a que tu
as fait à redire comme tuer ça serait
mal de mer je te laisse perthus elle
n'empêche que j'ai déjà remarqué voilà
plusieurs fois que tu mènes et le but d'
aventure avant tout d'un coup il
faudrait s'entendre entre avoir une
maîtresse est allé explorer la face
cachée de la lune
j'ai quand même une petite nuance qu'est
ce que tu appelles une vie d'aventurés
rigole quand je dis bon et ben alors
c'est l'essentiel
d'accord je téléphonerai bon bon jour
mais au fait j'oubliais trois jours qui
doit de quoi tu as intérêt à éviter la
nationale pourquoi pas pardon j'ai dit
depuis la nationale
qu'est ce que ça veut dire il y en a
rappelé la nationale je veux dire que
dans deux jours il y aura plus la route
nationale c'est pas possible pour mon
travail de deux voitures camions cette
brouille jour et nuit
alors je demande de repenser deschamps
sait
les clichés les tracés et alors ils ont
réfusé c'est pourquoi ensuite je demande
au ministère
non tu pas sérieusement évidemment
d'ailleurs j'ai eu tort il m'a envoyé
pendre et 9 à ça ça doit être le
ministère de l'agriculture
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que tu dis j'ai
dit que je me suis adressé à nyc vln toi
toi tu mois ge au nom mais bien qu'est
ce qui te fera bien par quoi lire ni qu
elle n
l'homme qui vend du tout m et n'importe
quoi
je lui ai demandé de voler la route
nationale
non mais tu attends attends tu connais
munich vers même toit comme tout le
monde mais je n'en je veux dire je la
rencontrais mon cher ami
on ne rencontre pas yves heller on les
contacte puis je ne sais pas pourquoi je
te raconte tout cela ben bella des parce
que ça me passionne futur toit et
comment l'as-tu contacter
comment comment les fêter là dans deux
jours nous vivront en paix il me semble
que tu pourrais mairie
mais oui bien sûr bon mais que geoffrey
très très attention le soir en rentrant
je te promets maintenant je fis un et
cynique verlaine vient voyait la
nationale tu fais car quillan même pas
la maison avec un grand et était jaloux
jaloux tu es jaloux parce que nick van
halen louis sera capable de la volée la
tour eiffel est bien d'accord sujet
allez on parle plus de tout ça moi je
n'aurai plus la tour eiffel et toi tu ne
me parle plus de sony du verlaine
donnant donnant
cinq mois en mois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
paris
qu'est ce que tu dis
[Musique]
et pourquoi habitude je t'emmerde
ce sommet
francis [ __ ] groupe
au fond je la prends pour une débile et
j'ai tort alors forcément elle se
rebiffe et le rêve elle invente la fa
bull mais tout de même me dire à moi
qu'elle a appelé ni verlaine ça c'est
dingue non ce qu'il faudrait quand on y
réfléchit ce serait peut-être sûrement
même lui dire la vérité je suis sûr
qu'elles le méritent la vérité oui
oui mais comment carrément
[Musique]
oh
il faut en finir j'ai eu une révélation
graves dérives l'essentiel est fait
qu'est ce que tu vas me dire tu ne vois
pas que je travaille ici chaque fois
mais écoute moi mélangez bien fait alors
ses versions c'est plutôt pour demain
[Musique]
oui et bien comme ça c'est vrai à des
joueurs comme un toit
[Musique]
vais pêcher ni fair l'aisne c'est moi
quoi toi qu'est ce que tu lui as fait un
unique merlen n'ont rien je dis
simplement nick verlaine c'est moi je
suis knicks verlaine
[Musique]
[Rires]
claudia pour une urgence
évidemment il n'y a pas de grand homme
pour son épouse
non il faudrait une preuve plus précise
crête qu'est ce que je voulais dire
hélène ce cas as-tu déjà songé au nom je
porte
nicolas alba oui parce que toi tu
m'appelles cola mais une supposition
tu pourrais m'appelait nique nique
remous nick rimbaud ni très beaux ni
grimbosq étoiles tous à votre nom
justement si tu changes collard n'y fit
aussi bien changé rabaud en un autre nom
notre peau est également verlaine par
exemple
tant qu'à faire je préfère de la matinée
j'étais à flairer alphonse et si je lui
racontais ma vie ça serait indiscutable
à la naissance d'une vocation
parce que c'est vrai j'avais à peine six
mois quand tout a commencé venu
parce que je détestais l'odeur de
caoutchouc mais dont soudain c'était
réglé en moi oui les tétines j'avais
posé là pour tous et comme je n'aimais
pas le lait non plus ce que j'en avais
fait je ne m'en souviens et d'ailleurs
ça c'est mon secret n'empêche que
précocement l'escamotage devenait pour
moi une seconde nature
à 21 ans alors là c'était déjà du
fignolage pas de boutons à droite ni à
gauche mon colonel
après quatre jour le jour par bateaux
alors mon ami la soupe est bonne
excellente mon colonel
alors mon ami la soupe est bonne non
colonel on en parlera alors mon ami
la soupe est bonne bof dans ma roue mais
le point est meilleur thomas hommes
excusez moi monsieur mais monsieur
monsieur je ne suis pas un monsieur je
suis colonel vous n'avez pas vu mais
galan bas c'est que justement monsieur
on m'a volé mes galons à dieu dans deux
semaines à san juan
depuis quand vous permettez vous de
porter cinglant pour le nail jamais je
ne me permettrais et ça alors qu'on a vu
dans mon colonel
je vous jure que je comprends c'est
c'est à cette même époque que j'ai connu
ma femme
et
[Musique]
je rêve pour vous plaît messieurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame oui c'est beaucoup mieux que
chercher votre voiture
[Musique]
bientôt
ebewe debout
[Musique]
je vais pas demander vague annie mercier
mais c'était l'argentine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
obama
[Musique]
c'est charmant
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
enfin sol
[Applaudissements]
non non non ce n'est pas le repas de
noces d'ailleurs vous le voyez en est
entre hommes attendez les gars j'ai un
mot à dire à quelqu'un sovo c'est merci
est ce quelqu'un c'est lui
abu dis ça comme la vie on aurait jamais
eu la réjouissante surprise de voir
disparaître comme par enchantement le
fusil mitrailleur du sergent-chef la clé
la clé de la salle de police
lequel sont brodés du capitaine le trou
des waters réservés aux officiers le
plan de mobilisation générale les diallo
du colonel et même ô miracle
les asticots dans le calme et sans
penser des baigneurs grâce à lui on aura
passé dans celle de réputés généralement
sinistre 18 mois complet de franche
rigolade et on soit remercié
[Applaudissements]
les copains d'abord merci oui voilà 18
mois qui viennent de s'écouler pendant
lesquels nous avons peut le dire braver
l'enduire rails et l'inutile dénoncé le
dérisoire chasser le ridicule et
pourfend de legrand d'axway
mais attention à tout ceci a été plus
qu'un amusement est une philosophie et
c'est pourquoi je lève mon verre à tous
ceux qui sauront façonner l'avenir à
l'image de cette philosophie
oui alors compter sur moi pour vous
montrer le chemin et pour le reste eh
ben je fais confiance à vos talents poil
aux dents
l'accusation s'est levé
et
[Applaudissements]
bon c'est vrai
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors toi qu'est louer un
pourquoi eh ben le portefeuille du loup
qui a ses points beaucoup alors t'as
rien compris
ça me fait rigoler la dernière les
enduros là avec toi je me méfie tient le
portefeuille ici bien en place la
mission accomplie ça va bon bien oui
j'arrive à mon gars tu avais fait une
farce merde mon portefeuille et on peut
dire que vous n'êtes pas alors y'a pas
soirée au régiment on se fait les
amitiés qu'on peut lui on l'appelait
prospère je croyais que c'etait pas
plaisanterie eh bien nous quand on s'est
retrouvés à paris joue saluera beau
salut prospère en tant d'horreurs doit
aussi on peut compter cinq minutes
humble toi mon pote tu connais toi comme
tu es et le gars qu'il nous faut et pour
un autre explique à ses doigts qu il
envoie là
jamais je n'avais entrevue d'un avenir
plus radieux que celui qui m'offrait
prospère dans les figures hold-up
détournement de boeing rapt de pdg
enlèvement d'état c'était un choix de
moyens d'existence quel et du superbe au
somptueux en passant par le
resplendissant
mais moi je n'étais pas doué pour le
travail en association mon ami prospère
vous êtes encore faux saute
ma vocation était des sens purement
artistique d'une bassement commerciales
voire affairistes l'art pour l'art du
geste gratuit
c'est donc en parfaite ingénuité que
j'essayais honnêtement de réintégrer la
vie civile et civilisé numériquement et
cessent pas du tout jugement et s
essayent sécurité sociale à wigan a
battu alors là je ne connais pas par
coeur et ben allel à prendre monsieur
vous suivant on 07 75 432 heures
aujourd'hui à 37,75 432 0 0 2 1 39 75 80
mais pas vu rouge
papier j'ai oublié défaut de
présentation de cartes grises
connaissait numéro de voiture
30 07 75 432 0,02 et vous foutez de moi
ah ben non ça que ça finit par 75 38 73
achten 75 38 60 je voyais connaître par
coeur monsieur 38,73 h n 75 par la tête
non non rien 30 07 75
bah le reste est marqué mais votre
numéro de caisses de retraite
oui mais votre numéro d'été d'entre
elles parce que les caisses de retraite
ça ce numéro est aussi un peu oui
le prénom de votre grand-père mais c'est
bien pourquoi que c'est tabou que je
demande avec leur donnant donnant un je
vous donne le numéro de moi le nom de
mon grand père evo vous m'avouer votre
nom de jeune fille ça va vous vous
croyez mme allan et bien vous vous
référez ça sur dix exemplaires dont
trois sur papier timbré à 10,20 suivant
et que ça soit bien écrit
30 07 75 432 30 07 75 ils nous entendent
2 00 38 sousse centre est la chute
soixante nhl tout entière
à 30 07 75 4 132 00 à 30 07 75
[Applaudissements]
aux trois champions
40e
aux achats
[Musique]
oui
et
[Musique]
m
allo
allo prospère oui oui qui dont je
voulais demander dans ton boulot y'a pas
de sécurité sociale vient et b une
caisse de retraite n'ont plus qu'un et
l'urssaf
t'as jamais entendu parler bon
maintenant si je te dis que mon grand
père maternel s'appelait léon
qu'est ce que tu me répondras que tu
n'en a rien à [ __ ]
très beau parfait j'ai changé d'avis
j'arrive tout ça n'était pas si simple
d'entrée je senti que ce serait pas
encore idéal piquer un diamant dans une
résidence secondaire ça peut passer le
temps oui mais ça manque terriblement
d'humour toute la baraque et piéger un à
huy a oui sirène au porte saunerie dans
les tentures chausse trappes dans les
escaliers alors le seul moyen d'entrer
la fenêtre
ici le système d alerte est en
réparation alors moi je payais et toi
une fois rentrés dedans bas lors d'une
des brouilles 1 c'est un jeune enfant
bon toi seulement voilà
[Musique]
moi
et
mais oui j'avais encore réfléchi on
m'avait proposé de passer une fenêtre
pour voler un diamant j'avais préféré
voler la fenêtre et négligent le diamant
après un instant d'égarement j'avais
retrouvé une vérité définitive
ma vocation c'était le vol face le vol
défi lancé à la face d'un monde de
violence est profit prospère m'avait
prêt pour arsène lupin l'erreur
fondamentale
je garde quand même de bonnes relations
avec lui il est venu dîner à la maison
récemment il plaît beaucoup à ma femme
[Musique]
enfin passe devant ah oui tiens toi
tranquille sécher un joujou comme ça à
la prochaine protell du sceau du fait
pas le mérion aller
allez allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas de bêtises en termes si bien
gentiment oui
[Musique]
et
mon
[Musique]
et vive la casse
c'est toi c'est amusant j'aurais déjà dû
reconnaître tes méthodes
comment ça va monter vieux ça va non ils
t'ont pas brutaliser j'espère non tu
prends 6 ans était d'une courtoisie un
peu timide peut-être oui on allait au
rip et vos autres on a causé sérieux est
un bon je te préviens je suis pressé
j'ai vu un coup de téléphone je sais
comment tu sais c'était moi mais ça n'a
pas toi tu pourrais pas me le dire
je me méfie un peu les écoutes assieds
toi
mais alors pourquoi ici bas pour parler
affaires on est plus tranquille une
grosse paire tu sais ce que je t'ai rit
oui
sur le plan des affaires nous n'avons
plus rien à voir ensemble
alors je te rassure tout de suite c'est
pas ensemble c'est toi toi tout seul je
t'amène un client ah oui marantz au
moins non dans la sphère est marrante à
un banal et puis plutôt bien payé oui
mais ça je m'en fous complètement
l ambiance est ce qu'on va voir voilà le
chèque non je suis je me fous du chèque
si l'histoire ne sort pas de l'ordinaire
il s'agit d'une lutte anti pollution
alors tu vois je peux pas mieux de dire
bon voila tu m'intéresses vas-y je
t'écoute
tu remarqueras que je vais faire au
porteur c'est à dire que si tu n'es pas
d'accord je pourrais le encaissé moi
même
ouais tiens comme sa forme c'est juste
ma banque un risque est encore plus
drôle c'est à ses pendants numéros de
comptes tu vois c'est ma signature
mais bon dieu mais j'ai jamais signé un
chèque de 10 millions moi et mon porteur
en plus soit non mais ta femme oui nommé
rodéo pour l'instant le porter c'est
blanc rend moins sonore des clopes tu me
vois ma prospère tarière la confiance
d'une dame
si tu veux le récupérer ton chèque tu
n'as qu'une manière elle est simple elle
est complètement ce réglage épouse une
cinq ans d'un corner battu pomme
demander ou moins ce qu'elle veut mais
je sais très bien ce qu'elle veut elle
veut que je lui vaut la route et
nationale qui passe devant la maison et
ballon et trouve pas ça drôle toi
pas dans ces conditions le déficit est
marrant de tir un chèque de 10 briques
sous le nez et puisque tu veux le
récupérer ce chèque ça j'espère bien une
seconde je téléphone et j'arrive
alors là on est en plein délire et n'a
jamais atteint des sommets par allo ici
ni fermé alors c'est pour le cas pour
jamais non c'est pas possible
d'ailleurs on vous a émis un chèque
justement la signature me paraît
suspecte mais c'était normal c'est
possible mais elle me paraît pas
authentique pratique pas tandis que
monsieur mais c'est moi même qui est
limité mais précisément madame il
faudrait que la signature de votre mari
soit effectivement celle de votre mari
qu'est ce que ça change d'agent imite à
la perfection
bon si vous voulez mais chien vous dire
que votre histoire ne m'intéresse
absolument pas monsieur vous allez me
faire mourir je vais bien monsieur que
je ne peux plus vivre dans ces
conditions cette route mène la folle à
voler dans les délais prévus
génisses ils vivent l'état mais madame
bien peut-être solution plus raisonnable
à trouver par exemple si cette route
vous ennuie tellement pourriez peut-être
déménager au revoir monsieur que vous
connaissez dans mon mari est qu est ce
qu un votre mari ce n'est pas de faire
un nom
marie mottet mais c'est un bourgeois
il ne supporte plus jamais de
bouleverser ses habitudes changent c'est
pas tous des places modifie orientations
de son lit voulait les tuer messieurs
mais absolument pas madame je préfère
mourir moi même et sachets cij a imité
dans là voilà la wii vous êtes quoi
alors j'attends donc que notre affaire
soirée dans 48 heures sinon adieu
monsieur mai à la halle aux non madame
madame je dis adieu monsieur
[Musique]
alors peu plus en plus cinglés au forum
mon cher camarade tu sais pas ce que tu
veux si tu étais beau joueur tu
conviendras que je suis ton meilleur
élève parce que c'est une farce comme
celle là il faut la faire alors
[Musique]
et bien valu chouravé sa nationale
mais est ce bien la zone à
sylvette j'ai un terrain aménagé un
rendement lieu sylvette but
occupez vous plutôt nyon bon vous avez
téléphoné chez robert pépiniéristes j'ai
besoin d'un hectare et demi de gaz dans
ce match c'est à livrer ici mais à vous
offrir un double prix parce que c'est un
travail de nuit vous allez faire planter
du gazon la nuit qu'est ce que vous
croyez qu'ils font qu'ils attendent six
mois peu soleil solaire ah bon
[Applaudissements]
à auch
[Musique]
pour nous
mme banon
[Musique]
oh
simon
en moyenne
ça marche ces trucs là
ii makoun il me parle c'est moins
dangereux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plutôt mignon
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
j'attendais on va y aller et ça c'est
quoi alors inquiétez pas c'est autorisé
aux riverains
ah bon
alé lô
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la route il n'y a plus toute la lute a
disparu
[Musique]
et moi qu'est ce qu'on ferait pas par
une femme même pour la sienne douanes
ont bien quand les oiseaux
tu as vu revenir les vous êtes comme
parfait on va grandir les jardins ici le
dancefloor là mais l'enjeu des cyprès
t'as pas peur que ça fasse un peu
cimetière nous a bien attention de
mourir ici au nom même de rimbaud c'est
ici oui c'est pourquoi si vos frères
déménagement internationaux qu'est ce
que c'est que ça on déménage on déménage
mais on déménage je parle français non
on ne ménage c'est comme ça ça ne
pouvait plus durer
toute cette circulation la brouilly la
pollution hier soir jean naim a retrouvé
une petite bicoque dans ton kit je
téléphonais qui est beau frère c'est de
la folie puisqu'il n'y a plus de route
c'était sans merci si bon les quinquas
et plus en plus tard écoute dit à ces
gens qui peuvent repartir à vide des
commandes n'est fait ce que tu vois
tiens chanteur quelque chose moi je m'en
lave les mains
on avait du mal à vous trouver
vous aviez parlé d'une route mais a pas
de route déménager après tout le boulot
que j'ai fait messieurs vous prendrez
bien quelque chose je vais vous
expliquer une petite bricole mais c'est
tout
[Musique]
des chats
paris c'est l'éducation
via guardian la faute est reconnue est à
moitié pardonnée
en fait de management je veux dire mais
ne tournons pas autour du port je
voulais vous simplement envie d
apprendre petit déjeuner avec nous alors
ça vient ce déménagement quoi aurait des
ménages je déménage te des ménages nous
déménageons et vous vous déménagez et
plus vite que ça
nicolas puisque la route et la route
mais qu'est-ce qu'on a besoin d'une
route sûre qu'on a besoin d'une haute
sinon pour amener le camion jusqu'ici
comment on fait on le porte l'acquis
était pas elle va venir tout seul
[Applaudissements]
alalalala l'eau c'est très joli on
déménage mais voilà ta petite bicoque
quintais qu'il en ait qui prend à gauche
bon et après la précédente en août
jusqu'où ainsi marseille 800 bornes qui
ne traînent pas où aller déjeuner je
connais un bistrot parce qu'après c'est
pas fini bien sûr que non après
marseille tout à gauche car si lorient
offense à l'ess si on part pour le japon
prenons directement le canal de suez ça
sera plus rapide et quittez pas l'aider
japon en grèce où l'accord et gaz
c'est merveilleux c'est vrai qu'avec mon
bureau à paris ce sera tellement
pratique tarière qui cherche encore des
prétextes pour ne pas rentrer déjeuner
mais non
le pain de sucre
oui mais c'est un peu encombrant et tout
de même ça irait contre la protection
des sites le kremlin
[Applaudissements]
alors là ça risque de faire des
complications internationale
québec l'industrie serait comme ça tu
industries +2 stream des icebergs à
bordeaux des pingouins dans l'île de ré
mais bien réalise à propos de nick
verlaine nous vous avons réservé la
primeur d'un sondage réalisé par lee
fraysse et dont nous allons vous
communiquer les résultats qui vont
donner lieu dans la soirée à un débat
première question êtes vous très
satisfait assez satisfait plutôt
mécontents ou très mécontents de
l'action de nick v relève très
satisfaits 19% assez satisfait 62%
plutôt mécontents 17% très mécontents 2
% wallis et futuna 99,9 pour ça si l'on
analyse ces résultats par catégorie
socioprofessionnelle
nous trouvons sont satisfaits ou assez
satisfaits gai luron 92% lurons
ordinaire 63% pisse-vinaigre 0,01 pour
cent wallis et futuna 99,9 pour cent
sont plutôt mécontents ou très
mécontents hépatique est constipé 93%
truands et monte-en-l'air 92% ministre
de l'intérieur 100% wallis et futuna
99,9 pour cent
enfin la question êtes vous pour ou
contre l'arrestation de nick verlaine
pour 5 % contre 90 % sans opinion 5%
wallis et futuna 99,8 1,8 pour cent
excusez moi ah ben oui on me signale à
la régie cave wallis et futuna un décès
vient de survenir il ya quelques
instants
quoi qu'il en soit il nous semble qu en
conclusion nous pouvons reprendre la
toute dernière déclaration du
commissaire poilvert une police qui
arrêterait nick verlaine deviendrait
aussitôt une police impopulaire ce
journal est terminé merci de votre
attention bonne soirée
[Musique]
là
m
[Musique]
je m'appelle nicolas raimbeaux c'est moi
cette petite chose là bas fin c'était
moi il ya bref j'ai beaucoup grandi mais
ma grande et belle vocation c'est de
cette époque date
on dit que je vole nous nous non en
réalité j'ai escamote jeu subtilise
l'entourloupe et je m'amuse
on m'a proposé de faire carrière dans
l'escroquerie banal dans l'arnaqué
sordide
non non non non moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de braver l'ennui de railler le
ridicule mais gallou pourfendre les
halons pension et tout ça c'était plus
qu'un amusement mais pas un mot tout ça
à ma faim et lire tout pour elle pour la
police je suis nicolas raimbeaux agents
immobiliers par contre lorsque j'exerce
mes talons je prends un autre nom tout
aussi poétique d'ailleurs verlaine nique
il ne reste qu'un grand problème à
résoudre
sacré nom d'un chien comment voler la
tour eiffel
[Musique]
on
tiens baic était pas là cette année là
la réputation de nick verlaine s'étendit
et s'installa définitivement delà des
frontières
on l'avait cru le most il fallait bien
vite revenir sur cette appréciation
hâtives les facéties de nick verlaine
recommencèrent d'égayer un monde au bord
de la morosité la dépression nerveuse
l'ennui pernicieux et le suicide le
régressait notablement dans les
statistiques foutu la baguette
quant à nick lui même il ne risquait
plus d'avoir de problèmes qu'avec son
percepteur encore que sont pas soumis
dossier mais il y en a plus un seul de
son côté la police continuait d'évoluer
dans le plus épais débrouillards le
rapport où elle rapporte vers les
incroyables pas de football rapport
trouvez-moi le rapport
quant à sa femme elle persistait
doucement mais inébranlablement à vivre
dans un monde de rêve
[Musique]
mais où est ma pétition pour la traviata
et la partition de la traviata
voilà voilà
gimeno nigrum donne à la baguette un
parker
voilà ça le rapport du commissaire
walbert beaucoup plus à la
oh bien direz vous mais dans ce cas
comment était il donc possible d'entrer
en contact avec nick verlaine puisqu'il
s'entourer d'un tel mystère
eh bien nous chuchote mais que nous
jetons et que certains de ses premiers
clients sous la présidence de prosper
avait constitué une association des amis
de nick verlaine société tellement
secrète que nick lui même
on ignorait l'existence d'une sorte de
franc maçonnerie où l'on entrait qu'à
force de recommandations parrainage
serment solennel et rites d'initiation
impitoyable
messieurs je vous remercie d'avoir fait
diligence et bien maintenant ne perdons
plus d'une seconde
il est temps de passer à la cérémonie du
serment voulez-vous me suivre monsieur
je jure ne jamais avoir ni dans le
présent ni dans l'avenir le moindre
rapport avec la police je jure ne jamais
avoir été ne pas être il ne jamais
devenir l'amant de la femme d'un
policier parfait et maintenant nous
allons procéder à l'initiation
proprement dit
et oui c'est toujours par les bonnes
femmes contrat il est secret il faut
savoir résister à l'épreuve
allez allez allez refusé jamais avoir
été ainsi l'association ce serait peu à
peu établi sur la planète entière s'est
jamais avoir été ne pas être nine
devenir l'amant légende ou vérité ne
jamais savoir et et ne pas être de tout
simplement que cette hypothèse est l'une
des rares susceptibles d'expliquer
d'étranges événements et qui survinrent
à cette époque
pardon
[Musique]
si l'on prend
merola
et j'ai compris à la rigueur on tue les
hommes mais on ne touche pas aux bêtes
même si on ne fait pas exprès n'y aura
pas d' excuses je milite à la société
protectrice des animaux pas la ligue des
droits de l'homme
et maintenant la ferme
s
la caisse oui la caisse la caisse
la voilà à la caisse tu te fous de moi
sur quatre anciens occupants
oui bonjour monsieur incident il
s'agirait d'un hold up armés c'est à
dire que si vous le prenez sur ce ton il
pourrait ne s'agir que d'un simple
transfert de fonds
encore faudrait-il qu'il y ait défend
évidemment l'emmerdant pour vous cher
monsieur c'est que nous sommes
parfaitement renseignés vous êtes passé
hier à la banque friedman pour négocier
florin francs suisses deutsche mark
si vous êtes le contrôle des champs
c'est différent vous aimez suivre
c'est en queue de convoi après vous
alors comme ça vous pas aussi qu'on va
avoir une dévaluation
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça et
apparemment vous ne fait confiance
qu'aux monnaie forte a on peut rien vous
cacher et ben vous voyez ça me fait de
la peine
quoi dans de vous priver de vos petites
économies bien géré bien gardé comme ils
sont bien gardés vous ne croyez pas
c'est bien d'ailleurs
voilà c'est ici
cez arena
excusez moi je ne pouvais pas prévoir
et croyez moi cet animal ne parlerai
qu'en présence de son avocat
je veux dire qu'il fera de concessions
que sur l'ordre de 100 danseurs alors
aller chercher on sait pas on dit cross
l'illustrent rudy cross mais ne voyage
qu'en wagonlit première classe on doit
le retrouver après demain si vous voulez
prendre rendez vous je sois le premier
qui touche c'est moi qui le descend ça
papa non tu vois pas qui fout de nous
question susceptibilités c'est moi le
jeu grand caniveau moulinette monsieur
il ne me reste qu'à vous présenter mes
regrets
de toute évidence affaire a été mal
préparé la part d'imprévu sous-évalué
nous aurions mauvaises grâces insisté ou
envoyez désolé et tue les fils evan ou
dénoncer et non c'est quoi un brin de
causette au bord d'une route c'est pas
un délit non elle est haute
vous commencez à me courir sur le
haricot on affaire d'une bataille on n'a
pas perdu la guerre on a paumé trente
briques erreurs nos trente briques sont
parfaitement à l'abri vous l'avez vu ça
sent la vue on l'a vu quand vous aurez
compris que leur hold up n'est pas
affaire de brutes épaisses mais une
délicate oeuvres d'art arrête ton char
bon vous êtes trop con pour comprendre
d'accord alors je vais résumer on n'a
pas pu voler la caisse d'accord mais
pourquoi à cause du tigre
donc si auparavant on vole le dj dhr on
pourra ensuite piqué la caisse question
de méthode
ben voyons shourd avait indiqué en août
1 il suffit d'y mettre un grain de sel
sur le zizi pisser dans la poche
c'est fou ce qu'il devient vulgaire
devant l'obstacle j'ai parlé de voler le
tigre
j'ai pas parler comment ni par qui tu
veux engager du personnel intérimaire
quelque chose comme ça une fois encore
c'est l'association des amis de nick
verlaine qui se charge avec la plus
grande discrétion et établir le contact
m
je l'entends pas colas oui je ne sais
pas si c'est la n va
en fait c'est la fête la spl espérandieu
quecela à c'est la femme de jean ries
espérandieu né à nîmes en 1829
architectes de notre dame de la garde à
marseille est mort des 874 s'est mis lui
n'y est là bon qui sait c'est là espère
metz plage pur et c'est cela la spa
société protectrice des animaux place la
société protectrice des animaux
mais qu'est ce que je t'ai encore fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
mais on souffre
simone
césar veut des mairies c'est assez jeune
jules ça ou pardon pardonnez moi
j'espère que je vous ai pas se mettront
mal je me présente caruso enrico caruso
mais complet ne vous inquiétez pas pour
le chien
je m'en occupe excellente entre une
espèce d'abruti un peu plus c'est mignon
treki découvert de monsieur raimbourg
peu d entrée je suis enchanté ne vous
connaître monsieur rimbaud prenez un
siège monsieur verlaine oui qu'aurais-je
affaires d'un agent immobilier
nos locaux sont vétustes
donc pour vos animaux disposent d'apple
du minimum vital indispensable mais mais
mais mais que pourrais-je faire avec les
maigres ressources dont nous disposons
vous êtes un ami des pets
vous aimez les faux monsieur vernet ma
femme aimerait tassé portée du léopard
mais personnellement je la préfère tout
nu et bien moi aussi mais comment vous
aussi non je veux dire que moi aussi je
suis contre ce genre de les gants ce qui
suppose le massacre des espèces comme ça
d'accord et si nous en venions au fait
cher monsieur monsieur
déjà cher monsieur saint michel
il y a un problème mais je vais vous
l'exposez non il y a un problème que moi
je vais vous exposer
vous dites que vous n'avez que de
faibles ressources mais si vous
connaissez ni verlaine vous devez savoir
le prix de ses services habituels
oui monsieur mais servait sow toujours
inhabitée monsieur j'ai le regret de
constater que vous pratiquez une odieuse
politique de classe ou non pardon je
constate comme au service pour aussi
outils et brillant qu'ils soient sont
réservés à une infime minorité de
privilégiés
vous êtes un ignoble réactionnaire
monsieur je vous prierais de noter que
mon entreprise est une des rares en
france à pratiquer l'auto gestion
gardez vous êtes 12 heures c'est
peut-être là la clé du problème monsieur
verlaine
si vous voulez que votre nom ne soit pas
lié à tous que notre société comporte de
futiles qu'inutiles de superflu de
décadent précis accepté au moins trente
ans dans ce que j'aurai cram de vos bons
sur vous écoute que voulez vous de moi
un geste et qui consisterait à ne pas
tendre la main
s'agirat ensemble de philanthropie
exactement alors précisé
écologie pollution protection des
espèces
vous connaissez j'ai entendu parler oui
alors le tigre à lang noir derniers
survivants de l'illustre dynastique
détail des plaques bastos ça vous dit de
gauche comme le dernier le seul le
dernier le seul et qu'est ce que vous
les voulez le sauver le rétablir dans
ses droits ancestraux le replacer dans
son milieu originel et naturel en un mot
assurer sa reproduction
monsieur saint michel je n'ai jamais été
tire de ma vie aussi un détail mais chat
commet cet animal seul peut-il faire
pour se reproduire
alors où vous me mentais où ces animaux
de sacré tour dans leur sac
oui mais c'est à dire que il est
possible sinon certains que le
complément femelles se trouvent encore
en afghanistan entre la vallée du bras
man et merka alors je devrai ramener
l'animal jusqu'en afghanistan à deux
mais pas du tout nous nous chargeons de
l'opération un malade mais comment avec
vos faibles moyens c'est à dire que là
aussi nous comptons sur certaines aides
bénévoles
en ce qui vous concerne nous ne vous
demandons qu'une chose sortir ce tigre
hors de sa cage cela est bien dans vos
capacités je vous dire dans vos talents
talent générosité désintéressement
courage quel homme
ex
traoré nerfs vous pourriez être monsieur
verlaine à moins évidemment que vous
n'ayez peur moi on va même plus la
drogue les grawls ont la pétoche la paix
dassary bravo il est évident que il faut
être très délicat avec ces petites bêtes
là elles peuvent se vexer bon allez
widgets et bien voilà
je commence à cerner une petite idée à
ness bien raisonnable beaucoup dois je
vous livrais la chose il nous serons
comme d'anonymes campeurs entre un champ
de maïs coupées et un petit bois à
l'ouest d'un village appelé blanche
fontaine ces vagues
oui c'est un terrain vague mais tout ce
qui est plus discret je vous ai fait un
petit plein pour y arriver
voilà un fait eh bien je vais préparer
la chose seulement du temps d'ores et
déjà il faudrait prévoir un certain
nombre d'accessoires indispensables
région et la cabine
justement des messages j'y tiens
beaucoup
[Musique]
vous avez des chiens prêt à l'élever
monsieur saint michel monsieur saint
michel ça sera dit bric à prendre ou à
laisser
le couteau sous la gorge je ne sais pas
ce que vous avez à faire de ce tir et je
ne veux pas le savoir ce que je sais
c'est que vous venez de vous [ __ ] de
moi te voyons voyons oui oui il doit y
avoir un regrettable malentendu non pas
du tout j'ai très bien entendu et vous
aussi
alors je répète ce sera 10 briques et je
veux un avaloir à mon bureau
demain matin monsieur mes salutations
[Musique]
il parle
c'est ma carrière je dis que tu pas
seulement ma carrière ah non chérie j'ai
pas dit que je pensais à rien eh bien
merci temps des fêtes est élevé toi même
oh non mais attends à rien non je
voulais dire je penser à ta carrière
base et qui n'est rien par rapport à
belle carrière future
pas la peine d'essayer de faire attraper
d'ailleurs du dessin il y en a pas oh il
évolue en effet une crème 7,4 en bobine
kremlin verset non aux pommes fraises
tiens tu me fais penser à quelque chose
oui je dire mais je pars savoir où et
pourquoi à la campagne pourra faire la
campagne pour la fin du mobilier oui
alors il faudrait trouver entre chance
bas que ceux qui te disent avant mais
quand j'arrive en tubes du jeune mort
alors que tu marmaille
bon alors je vais te dire arrête alors
là voilà on va voir si tu peux supporter
la faim j'en ai marre de voir tous les
jours les mêmes bobby alors je pars avec
une grande et grosse blonde qui est une
grosse moustache noire et tu sais ce que
je vais faire avec cette grande et
grosse blonde à moustache rumba
ad je ne pense pas moi et ça continue je
vais te montrer moi
et
vous allez rire
michel les fonds non celle ci interdit
époque mais pas mais voyez vous même
signature nos ports forme a remarqué le
français
il ya trop de données
[Applaudissements]
cherchez une dédicace une vraie
[Musique]
ah ah
monsieur sammy cher monsieur saint mich
[Musique]
et tout est du bidon
allez paris
ans
[Musique]
à
alors
[Musique]
mich berruti
ce mythe bravo monsieur saint michel à
sa signature
[Applaudissements]
à celle-ci ou non cette signature la
salle qui est déposé à votre banque
si vous y tenez comme ans et j'y tiens
comme un oeil à sa prenait là parfait
quand ça ira pas encore comment pas
encore
reste à régler les détails de
l'opération ça je suis à votre
disposition
quand comment commencer mon affaire
quand disons je demande 24 heures pour
la préparation disons lundi soir 23
heures
on aimerait que ce soit la minute près
mais pourquoi puisque vous n'avez qu'à
attendre la livraison c'est justement on
voudrait pas être inquiet bon alors
disons 23h15
on mêle aux montres à l'heure g20 j'ai
25 à l'heure où j'ai rien comme ça si
vous êtes en retard vous aurez
d'avenches oui mais vous vous certains
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on coupe la
poire en deux 22 ou non pavane en vain
normale en disant 23,1 comme ça personne
ne vient
demandez-moi parlé au téléphone
743 05 07
et vous me passez la communication dans
la chambre on dire merci on entend
maelen
je répète ou quoi oui oui j'ai dit
ouvrez moi immédiatement un nouveau
compte
oui à nouveau compte oui et transférer
la totalité de mon à voir oui je dis la
totalité de mon avoir je ne veux plus
rien sur mon ancien compte c'est urgent
allô allô la banque sussfeld
mademoiselle lg un chèque à prélever un
chèque de 50 mille francs a prélevé sur
le compte 48 102 x 67 voulez vous me
dire si ce conte est approvisionné s'il
vous plaît non et depuis quand est-il
plus approvisionné depuis trois minutes
pourriture le nom c'est pas bon
et c'est reparti au fond je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'insiste avec ces sauts zola
ya rien à faire
allez j'écrase à la maison terminée pour
le tir
[Musique]
et les bateaux ce cas là tu m'aimes
amélie sans nous et ils ont les mains
alors on laisse tomber le client mais
qu'est ce que vous faites ici vous je
vous attendais et qui vous ali j'allais
rentrer mon petit doigt
j'écris au les mains alors non non non
pas celui là il vaut au moins quatre
centrales plus un paquet de biscottes
alors on cause non on part pour part si
je veux vous le voulez maintenant
justement alors on combine à la noix vos
chèques sans provision vos provisions sa
signature et vos signatures sans que
l'état je commence à en avoir ras le bol
c'était prévu pourquoi montois lâchage à
cause du gel sans provision intéressés
comme vous êtes
c'est pourquoi je suis là perspicace un
plus
un bravo mais rien à faire les dents au
faty vous a permis d'entrer on a sonné
on nous a ouvert vous ça vous fait re
construit ma femme en voyage qu'est ce
que vous dites
du côté de blanche fontaine avec le
grand aux jo quoi on d'âge l'a répété
moi ça j'ai dit otages embarquer jusqu'à
la fin de l'opération n'a rien qu'à vous
regardez je suis obligé tourcoing et
alors elle n a rien fait n'a rien changé
je veux dire n'a rien dit elle a
simplement demandé où était notre avion
elle n'a pas l'air de comprendre qu'on
puisse prendre un otage sans détourner
d'allemand j'espère qu'il aime l'opéra
par jour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on est quoi on chantait toujours
comme ça n'ont découragé certains
conflits mal
il aurait dû commencer par là par quoi
à la menace ça vous aurez dispensé de
gestes inélégant j'avais confiance en
votre parole et matam elle est au
courant
jamais les gonzesses je suis content
mais pas bavard
[Musique]
alors c'est d'accord pas de bêtises je
tiens ma femme
demain soir comme prévu dit dans un
dernier mot oui c'est du million tout
votre histoire
laquelle est notamment maintenant le
tigre un tuyau sa mort sa bave ça gueule
ça vous bouffe un gars en moins d'un
coup de cuillère à pot 1
alors qu'est ce que vous allez en [ __ ]
de ce tir pourquoi prendre tant de
risques on a déjà dit que j'étais notre
affaire pas la vôtre bon comme vous
voulez mais vous avez tort de me laisser
à la perplexité
je suis d'une nature curieuse vilain
défaut
on ne se refait pas non mais on peut de
faire de bonnes femmes pensent à ça je
ne vous raccompagne pas non je
regagnerai
c'est cuit un tube à notre président
c'est pas étonnant avec l'autre qui
braille
moi je trouve qu'elle est plutôt en
progrès mais le souverain
je suis plus en état d'apprécier lors ne
pas lui filer à becqueter sale affaire
au moins pendant cinq minutes pour une
fois quelque chose juste ils ont
qu'est-ce qu'on n'entend pas tu le
demandes à bon dieu je t'écoute
jaune juste c'est déjà pour le versant
est qu'elle soit accompagnée par
l'ochestre l'opéra
[Musique]
la clé c'est tiré par les ailes s'étirer
pardon madame on étouffe la gare
la guerre c'est par là mais si si pour
paris il n'ya pas avant demain matin
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
préparez vous à des surprises on le voit
par cet élan monsieur là le tir le dire
à l'homme noir
non monsieur reding a jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
céline est
est ce que tu es
[Musique]
ça vous intéresse oui oui wind cries et
bien ramener au genre de visites
volontiers mais je crains que ce ne soit
trop tard
alors on aurait pu revenir un peu plus
tôt que tu essaies pas un problème
pourquoi
mais le présentez vous jamais sur la
piste donné qu'elle essayait vous
comprendrez il ya quelque chose
d'extraordinaire oui son appétit il
bouffe il dévore
il est pas que l'on me cogne la ruine
lisant le mot et pourtant on veut vous
le volet
si monsieur non monsieur n'est pas le
titre convoler même pas la première fois
d'ailleurs
le coffre est dit donc pour voler le
coffre il faut d'abord enlever lutte
c'est pourquoi je dors tranquille vous y
fiez pas trop
il ya beaucoup d'argent là dedans des
années de labeur
mon père m'a appris à ne pas faire
confiance aux banques
là alors tout s'explique pardon écoutez
j'ai de bonnes raisons d'en vouloir à
ceux qui veulent vous voilez parce qu'on
veut vous volez alors je vous propose ma
collaboration on me laissait faire je
leur prépare une petite fête
j'ai déjà une petite idée derrière la
tête et alors là pas du tout raisonnable
[Applaudissements]
mary aller là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a perdu
[Musique]
merci c'est moi où
alors mon souci ça va bien
[Musique]
m
les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'un nouveau club est mort moi
je me planque
l'essab ça fait mal
[Musique]
oh
qui
ouais
[Musique]
non
oh
jusqu'à encore monsieur ce n'est qu'une
commotion
c'est pas une raison pour se décider
est-ce qui vous parle de se défouler
tout sera fait comme prévu à l'heure
prévue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rés
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la magnifique
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoi
c'est leur riche qui font qu est-ce qui
va [ __ ] surtout quoi quoi tu aurais pu
demander des précisions par sa précision
précision il va piquer le fond qu on
verra bien et si tu en fais nous enfonce
dans la cage pour élever le butin et est
d'ailleurs chez vous tout au regard d'un
hélicoptère
m
ce système pays va chanter ou quoi
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette ville
qu'est ce que c'est que cette combi mais
regardez moi c'est au foiral et il
emmène là car il sait pas ce qu'on lui
connaît les guettent
l'ess la cage le 10 octobre
l'estacade le dit
[Musique]
ok le scénario il a rien compris se
trouve à nous livrer à domicile
et puis signera le boulot au camping et
ben espérons noms suivants libre
[Musique]
surprise
à les combiner
est ce que vous vouliez à quai vous
l'avez
à
[Musique]
don le tigre ou d'un bon je prends deux
questions idiotes on s'en fout le
coffret l'asvel on a du mal à
[Musique]
j'ai poussé
alors voilà alors il sent la wii en
quelque sorte vous connaissez rudy cross
l'illustrent docteur jean ses trésors et
ben justement vous tombez bien si vous
voulez vous donner la peine mais
mais qu'est ce que vous lui avez donné à
bouffer
les gars où sont les gars sens là où ça
à l'intérieur
et oui b russie était bon pour les
animaux l'animal un très bon pour lui
[Musique]
attention ça va
eh ben dis donc tu n'es pas contente
il n'a pas ouvert la bouche depuis sa
sortie et du et guéri
bah zut quelque chose et contre
n'importe quoi mais dit quelque chose
j'ai un peu faim je mangerais bien une
petite biscotte
mais qu'est ce qui t'arrive
c'est la commotion j'ai changé de voie
alors carmen nimy l'outil à de
lammermoor c'est fini foutu pour moi on
est non mamouth cas il ya il ya des tas
de répertoire pour toi je ne sais pas
moi méphisto par exemple c'est tout à
fait dans ses cordes
mephisto attend le podium est toujours
debout mais tiens ça marche
ah ça marche tu avais raison le fondeur
est toujours debout
on a 100
sa puissance
ans on en sent seule sa puissance
on n'ose ans sa puissance on encense sa
puissance on encense sa puissance
ans sarah puissant
11 bon ça va c'est bien c'est très bien
ça suffit comme ça c'est bien
j'ai encore une bonne idée avec ça
[Musique]
oh
et
à
[Musique]
et